[Musique]
chantal simard dans le rôle d'amandine
alias la bande bleue david fusé dans le
rôle d'un real
marie paule rauzan dans le rôle de
nicole
[Musique]
on est aux habitations saint marc qui
notation hlm pour venir faire des
prestations pour les personnes aînées
qui sont résidents ainsi par action à
leur balcon d'où le nom de notre projet
les balles confiné recherche
d'appartements à louer n'avez-vous à
jour ici ces petits dés là est né dans
ma tâche et ce matin en faisant comme
artiste qu'est ce que nous on pourrait
faire pour rejoindre les gens et comme
artiste de rue notre spécifique c'est
d'être dans la souplesse et la proximité
du public
j'ai lancé la perche et elle a été
attrapé par un organisme communautaire
qui s'appelle les habitations nouvelles
avenues
[Musique]
c'est un projet où la culture en compte
le communautaire pour rejoindre les gens
et leur faire du bien
j'ai commencé très jeune à l'adolescence
à faire du théâtre de rue j'ai bifurqué
vers le domaine de la réadaptation en
utilisant l'art comme moyen
d'intervention auprès des gens
psychiatrie j'ai fait aussi de
l'humanitaire et depuis nombreuses
années mélange fait le théâtre de rue et
un peu de cirque
ça manque beaucoup de concentration mais
ça dure pas longtemps
qui alors dépêchez-vous pour les photos
ça en ayant un service essentiel je
pense que oui ça nous remonte le moral
j'ai entendu sawyer hausse comme une
thérapie pour nous comme on dit ça fait
ma journée puis je me disais peut-être
que ça fait davantage en tout cas de
marquer l'imaginaire des gens je pense
qu'ils vont rester avec chose de
réjouissant dans quelque part des
talents sont un peu haut mais ça vient
nourrir
quelque chose de fondamental je pense
comme artiste d'être en lien avec notre
communauté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils sont tellement heureux qu'on vienne
les voir qu'on s'approche d'eux dans
leur réalité donc on est très content de
vivre l'expérience parce que ça nous
apporte aussi beaucoup comme artiste à
bord on ignore on est là